have you come up with any theories as to
why cattle mutilations occur
me personally
or heard any that you found to be
interesting
well i wouldn't have any science to back
anything up so i could tell you i'm a
dreamer you know so i can come up with a
bunch of ideas i have some
um you know i've heard scientists
discuss
you know tracking our food supply you
know trying to see if there's
things that are in our food supply that
are affecting kind of how we evolve okay
that that was an interesting and there's
a lot more to it but it's not my place
to get into that um i've heard people
discuss that you know it's genetics or
something it's it's understanding
um a bit more about you know the life
here on earth or whatever then you get
into way more far out stuff is maybe it
has something to do with genetics with
man because maybe bovine type samples
deal with you know the blood or the i
don't know like the glands or something
to do with
you know people want to go way out and
be science fiction about it but i i just
don't know and i think
i just think that what we are hearing is
that
people are seeing lights and craft in
the sky in areas where they find these
things we know they're happening and
have been happening for decades and
decades like not just like a few like
thousands you know um but no one really
knows the reason why
maybe someone somewhere in some basement
knows but i i don't want to pretend that
i know because i don't but i do know
people been studying this for like 30
years and and um
and they all tend to say the same thing
it's like it's happening in a way
that doesn't look like we can pull off
what we're finding it just looks way i
mean they found cattle with organs like
their heart missing but no incisions
anywhere like somehow they reached in
and just grabbed it and pulled it out
you know so it's like what does that
mean what is i don't know but it's it's
it's wild for sure